Speaker 1: All right.
So let's follow up about the Aaron Rodgers
story.
Aaron Rodgers is apologizing to anyone that
felt misled.
OK.
Aaron Rodgers is sorry if he upset anybody.
Yeah.
So let's reset.
NFL quarterback Aaron Rodgers has issued a
pseudo bogus apology after getting caught
lying about being quote immunized against
COVID 19 catching COVID and then saying on
The Pat McAfee Show that he's been listening
to Joe Rogan for medical advice and is taking
ivermectin.
So it's like, where do we even start?
I guess let's kind of lead up to this.
First, here is a reminder this is Aaron Rodgers,
the Green Bay Packers quarterback in the summer.
This was in August.
Asked, Have you been vaccinated?
And he says, I've been immunized, which is
a different word.
And it was a lie.
It was a lie in conversation.
Speaker 3: Are you vaccinated and what's your
stance on vaccinations?
Yeah, I've been immunized.
You know, there's a lot of a lot of conversation
around it, around the league and a lot of
guys who.
Speaker 1: So the fact that this was a very
strange word salad might have been a sign
he was lying, have
Speaker 3: made statements and made statements.
Owners have made statements.
You know, those guys on the team that haven't
been vaccinated.
I think it's a personal decision.
I'm not going to judge those guys.
There's guys who've been vaccinated, contracted
COVID.
So it's an interesting issue.
I think we're going to see
Speaker 1: he's he's interested in the issue.
He's also lying, lying, lying so fine.
He lied about being immunized, vaccinated,
whatever.
He catches COVID.
Great.
So then he's going to miss last week's game
or a few days ago, Game admits that he was
taking and is taking medical advice from Joe
Rogan, who's a podcaster.
Joe Rogan is not a doctor, and when he says
this, we played this clip on Monday.
Pat McAfee can barely contain his laughter.
He actually has to cover his mouth to avoid
laughing directly in Aaron Rodgers face.
Let's go to that clip.
We looked at this on Monday.
Speaker 3: I consulted with a now good friend
of mine, Joe Rogan, after he got COVID, and
I've been doing a lot of this stuff that he
recommended in his podcast, Right?
And On the phone to me.
And.
I'm going to have the best immunity possible
now.
Speaker 1: OK.
So he made a lot of dubious claims in that
interview, where he said an Israeli study
says you get better immunity from just recovering
from COVID.
Of course, with the Israeli study says, is
that it's better not to catch it at all, but
that you get actually the best immunity from
recovery plus vaccination.
That's the best immunity.
So literally what he says is a lie there as
well.
So then comes the apology, and again, it's
one of these pseudo apologies.
New York Magazine's Benjamin Hart had a great
phrase.
He calls it the quintessential non-apology
apology to anyone that was upset.
This is a classic we've seen this time and
time again.
If anybody was upset because he lied to them
and put people at risk, he's apologizing.
If you found yourself upset by that.
OK, let's listen.
Speaker 3: So I just wanted to start off the
show by acknowledging that, you know, I made
some comments that people might have felt
were misleading.
And if you felt
Speaker 1: his obvious lies were misleading,
his completely demonstrable lies were misleading.
He's sorry that you felt that way.
Speaker 3: You know, to anybody who felt misled
by those comments, I take full responsibility
for those comments and I'm excited about feeling
better.
I'm excited by moving forward and hopefully
getting back on my team right and getting
back to doing what I do best and that's playing
ball.
It's been tough to be away from it.
I've been, you know, obviously dealing with
the COVID and I feel like I'm a woman on the
other side of it, thankfully and thankful
to still be able to have some look forward
to this weekend, hopefully.
Well, I appreciate you opening with that and
stating that, and you talked about the reflection
that you've had here, all by yourself in your
COVID cave over there in Green Bay.
Speaker 1: Right?
So it's a very crappy apology, but like, why
is he even doing it?
But this is starting to cost him money now.
We can't say for sure.
That's why he's issuing this.
You know, maybe he could have offered a better
apology, but he was dropped by a health care
company that he had been working with for
years.
Aaron Rodgers and Previa Health have ended
their nine year partnership, and Previa put
out a statement saying Previa Health remains
deeply committed to protecting its patients,
staff, providers and communities amidst the
pandemic.
This includes encouraging and helping all
eligible populations to become vaccinated
to prevent the virus from further significantly
impacting lives and livelihoods.
So private health making it clear we're not
going to do anything.
We're not we're not working with Aaron Rodgers
anymore.
State Farm cut most of its commercials with
Aaron Rodgers from being broadcast this past
weekend.
Now it seems that they're still continuing
the partnership for now, and they put out
a statement saying quote, We don't support
some of the statements he has made, but we
respect his right to have his personal view.
We recognize our customers, employees, agents
and brand ambassadors come with all walks
from all walks of life, with differing viewpoints
on many issues.
We encourage vaccinations but respect everyone's
choice to make but make decisions based on
their personal circumstances.
So that's the latest.
It seems as though, I mean, listen, at least
the timing is companies that pay Aaron Rodgers
have partially or fully stepped back or walked
away from those relationships, and he issued
this kind of bogus pseudo apology.
So what's the takeaway here?
I think the takeaway is get medical advice
from doctors.
Don't lie about being immunized or vaccinated
or whatever word you choose to use and don't
spread disinformation.
I mean, the takeaways aren't really any different
just because it's Aaron Rodgers rather than
your crazy uncle posting to Facebook.
It's really the exact same takeaways, and
we're going to have more on this on our Instagram.
You can follow The David Pakman Show on Instagram
at David Pakman show.
You can also follow me on Instagram at David
Pakman.
We're going to take a very quick break and
be back with much more right after this